latvia's largest soviet memorial has
been destroyed on the orders of national
parliament a concrete obelisk rising
nearly 80 meters into the sky formed the
centerpiece of the monument it
commemorated the red army's victory over
nazi germany in the second world war its
toppling is the latest example of an
ongoing trend in the baltic states and
eastern europe where relics of the
soviet union are being removed two's
killian byer reports from riga
meter upon meter of concrete steel
crashing to the ground
the monument may have been destroyed
but it leaves a political divide in its
wake
i feel wonderful because i experienced
the awakening of latvian independence in
the 1990s and now it feels like this
chapter's finally closed
just a few months ago riga's victory
park looked like this
it was the symbol of the red army's
victory over nazi germany a place for
ethnic russians to lay down flowers on
victory day to commemorate their
ancestors sacrifices in the second world
war
but the war in ukraine changed something
around one in four people living in
latvia are of russian descent
many of them cherish their soviet past
the majority of ethnic latvians however
see this monument as a symbol of russian
imperialism and are glad that it's gone
for latvians this monument symbolize
lattice occupation after second world
war
and after russia's invasion in ukraine
we can't
tolerate it anymore
on june 16th the latvian parliament
voted to remove all soviet-era statues
the monument in riga was the largest in
all of latvia
it took hours of continuous hammering to
eventually make it fall
with it gone some hope that the scars of
past can finally heal
and that russians and latvians can live
together peacefully
you